the gentleman I got to meet at the big
slick charity event in Kansas City many
many moons ago when we bonded I don't
care who knows that we bonded then and
he's welcome on the show anytime and
he's always in something interesting
whether it is west world or those who
have known him from his time on x-men
and also anchorman 2 and now he's undead
to me which is a fascinating fun wild
watch on Netflix and season 2 was
released Friday of last week he is James
Marsden how are you James I'm doing fine
where are you sheltered in place out
here in Los Angeles California or the
heartland where you're from I am sir you
uh yeah I've been up in my house last
six weeks and yeah just just hanging out
and and very lucky to be in sunny
Southern California and I'll do my best
to stay safe and take all you know the
precautionary measures attaboy I am I'm
in my Los Angeles studio because we're
you know the lights are on there's own
there's fewer than seven people here
every single day
I'm already I'm already normally
socially distant with my guys that I
work with anyway
they only need to they only speak when
spoken to James that's the way it rolls
here about you you like that you like to
walk around with an invisible force
field you've seen that could've been an
x-men myself you know what I mean just
in that regard James my own my own
special power I'm doing fine just doing
the show every day we're all good
tonight so let's let's get let's get in
a little sports talk with you how are
you still a die-hard fantasy football
player like non-stop you still in 19
leagues like when I first met you still
do you know what yes I am I was
introduced to the the fake sport about
ten years ago the one thing I do stick
to is I'm only in one league I just
spread myself out otherwise you can
always win right ya know so I do I did
do it I don't know how this year is
gonna go but which is you know I'm
remaining
hopefull we all are but well yeah the
obsession you know comes with with it
with the fall season and then there goes
all my anything that productive that I
was going to do because that window my
nine-year-old looked at me yesterday and
said dad is there gonna be a fantasy
football season and I've no I almost
weeped on the spot I almost did I'm like
yeah they're gonna do it hopefully there
is but yeah I got I got I got dad weepy
pretty much on the spot yeah yeah when
you're yeah when you're nine year old
looks up at you like that with his eyes
and ask that question he could he could
be I guess he could be asking anything
but then if it's football related it's
gonna add to it well you know and it's
it's it's odd I don't know if that says
anything about my panting skills I'm
like just sit down let's cheer up let me
put dead to me on where's Netflix did
you when they were when they were first
born did you toss them into the pool hey
man you get a cup for those who have
seen it you know exactly what I'm
talking about for those who haven't I
mean there's so much I don't want to
spoil right now um for for season two so
I'll just kind of give you the floor and
say what you know what that to me is for
you and what you've been and what fans
can expect for those who do know what's
going on
how about that yeah yeah yeah yeah no
it's it is a it is a spoiler yeah it's a
it's it's a it's a twist and turn heavy
show
so yeah the first season was last year
and I got picked up in second season I
you know I the first season I play kind
of a fun douche bag guy Steve and he
meets his demise at the end of it yes at
the hand of the lovely Christina
Applegate and I thought that was kind of
the end of it I was in for one season
and
well done and then the show became a big
hit and of course I had a little FOMO
and then I was like on my knees
groveling trying to get my warm my way
back into show right so I said let's
Feldman an email saying hey is there any
I've been googling if you think you can
survive a traumatic head wound drowning
is that is there any room for a
possibility of this guy like course
they're having this of course yeah of
course he said no thank you very much
nice try yeah yeah and then so did she
came back and was like you know what you
actually got me thinking and we were
trying to figure out a ways you know
bringing you back and I don't want to
ruin anything for anybody either but I
guess there's enough spoilers out there
to at least address you know in what
capacity I come back right what do you
think yes absolutely yeah I'm a twin
yeah well so we went down to classic
which you know admittedly a little side
of this sort of corny like come on give
me a break
but we sort of leaned into it mmm fun
with it this season it's a fun show to
watch man it's a fun show to watch and
Linda Cardellini is in it too and she's
just dynamite and and christina
applegate we had here on the show a
couple years ago it's kind of a way
James an anchorman reunion every day
that you have right there yes it is yeah
we Christina and I have worked together
twice before and never seen each other
we never saw each other on anchorman
because we never shared a scene together
right we also did a voiceover movie
together where we never saw each other
either because we just blended our
voices to the projects and this was like
a way for us to finally work together
for a third time right in each other's
actual actual company what was it like
on the anchorman to set James
give me a good story from that one story
from that one yeah it was I mean it's
just watching those guys do their thing
you know those boy
Paul and all the guys um from big slick
but yes it was amazing I mean this is
like its rarity you get that opportunity
to be a part of a movie or at least you
know that's the sequel to a film that
inspired you and in the in the comedy
world when you're trying to make it as
an actor in Hollywood and then it's
gonna come into anchorman 2 and play
with those guys it's like first of all
you better like you know you gotta be
shiny sharp but but it was amazing watch
I mean it was the most laid back it was
just a party it was like it mind
admitting in junior high or high school
and you and your buddies getting
together with a camcorder and you know
doing you know stupid little bits for
your own self satisfying amusements
right that was kind of the journey james
marsden here on the Rich Eisen show a
couple more minutes left with you sir
and I appreciate you taking the time
today on this Wednesday you are from
Stillwater Oklahoma so that it it's an
easy a skier right your your your
college team we all know who your
college team is correct that's right
yeah that's right I although I will say
oppor I I will say I was there for and
they shouldn't if it didn't have any
effect on my affection for the school
but I was there for three semesters to
sort of experience the social side of I
went to going to college in a fraternity
right
so my Allegiant is still with the
Cowboys to come but it but yeah it was
never I was never a diet you know
Oklahoma is diehard of course diehard
college college sports and um you know I
was more into the theater rich I was uh
I was honing that crash honing that
craft as opposed to because again I
imagine it's that Dallas Cowboys country
Oklahoma right it it it's like half
Dallas Cowboys hat Chief Jim slit right
down the middle and I at the time I
didn't really I was I was very
indifferent I know I knew I leaned more
toward the chief so I'm not just saying
that because they've they've been mom's
crazy lately
right and you know and winning but for
some reason I just grew up not not
vibing the Cowboys I don't know why
maybe maybe because so many people my
family like the Cowboys I just had the
contrarian that could be it and plus it
so is mahomes on your fantasy team is
that why you also because you're you got
a I never got I never got bat moms
although a friend of mine who joined our
league for the first time yes this year
no sorry last year was trying to draft
him early and I was like no no no that
you can wait on that guy like the 10th
11th round and I think he went like the
the 8th round and then of course was the
you know number one quarterback in the
year who are you in the league's is it
who are you in league with who are you
in a league with anybody there's anyone
named drop I I know in a league
yesterday I'm annelids I'll I'd earlier
two years ago I was in two leagues but
now I try to keep it in one league and
it's kind of a silly fun run with guys
okay it's it's it's like the Marvel
superhero action are you saying it's
like it's rod and it's Chris Evans and
it's did I drill down those guys yes so
Evans reached out to me about five years
ago and was like I know you're into this
game right when you want to come join
this and I was like with you know sure
yeah it looks like but it's like yeah
it's it's Jeremy Renner and and then
Krasinski and a bunch yet so it's a
crazy
it's about as annoyingly Hollywood as it
can get that's not annoying at all James
I think people are fascinated to see
whose ass you kicked so did you win it
did you know I was second this year
though - who who wanted who did win oh I
forgot who won I don't know
I forget Evans one has won two years in
a row
Orson so all we cared about was taking
him down guys all right yeah yeah and if
you ever need any help James I'm here
for you I can help
I know I've yeah I haven't seen you in
years
we run into each other occasionally yes
it always makes me very happy when I see
you right back at you and I know I
always written to come on here and talk
to you and I wish you obviously have
sitting opposite you and a good distance
I take it over the phone likewise
likewise because I miss you and and I'm
gonna try whatever the season whatever
the years are a year holds for the
season let's do it I'm gonna make I'm
gonna let switch stay in contact because
I'm gonna I'm gonna hope that there's
gonna be a season in some fashion I have
the same number jamesu then I'm gonna be
knocking on your door for some fantasy
oh I got the same number so let's stay
in touch and in the meantime dead to me
season 2 on Netflix starring James
Marsden along with Linda Cardellini and
Christina Applegate thanks for calling
brother you stay safe and healthy you
too buddy right back at you Jason you
gotta change marsden add James
underscore Morrison right here in the
Rich Eisen show